This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的 Learn the Hardway。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一套盔甲？它向世界释放信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习 Learn the Hardway。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
艾伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，建立精神坚韧、体能和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
也就是 TWA percent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we get into this episode, a little disclaimer, if you couldn't already tell from my voice,
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析我们20多岁的心理学。在进入本期节目之前，先做一个小声明，如果你从我的声音中还听不出来的话，
I am indeed a little bit sick with some mystery bug mystery illness, but of course the show must go on. I'm in Wyoming at the moment in the US, visiting some friends. And as an Aussie gal, the cold wet. weather does not agree with me one bit. And I seriously feel like I landed, spent like two hours in Wyoming and my body was like, we don't like this. Let's bring up any dormant viruses that you may have and bring them all to the surface. So if you can, please bear with me while I manage this cold virus, whatever it is, I would really, really appreciate it because I'm just really glad to share this episode with you. It's one that I have wanted to do for
我确实生病了，感染了某种神秘病毒或神秘疾病，但节目当然还得继续。我目前在美国怀俄明州拜访一些朋友。作为一个澳大利亚女孩，寒冷潮湿的天气实在让我吃不消。我真的感觉自己刚落地，在怀俄明州待了大约两小时，我的身体就在说：我们不喜欢这样。把你可能潜伏的任何休眠病毒都带出来吧，把它们全都带到表面。所以如果可以的话，请在我应对这个感冒病毒（无论它是什么）时多多包涵，我真的非常非常感激，因为我真的很高兴能与你们分享这期节目。这是我一直想做的一期，
a long time. I feel like I say that a lot, but it's because I always have these ideas on the back burner. Today I'm really happy to have you here for a very in-depth, dare I say, fun and fascinating episode on the difference between introverts and extroverts. Or should I maybe say what you think the differences are, but which we may have been misled to believe by the over-simplification of human personality. Extroversion is. and introversion seem to be this weird thing that divides society. Who are the social butterflies? Who are the hermits?
我觉得我经常这么说，但那是因为我脑子里总有这些备用的想法。今天我很高兴能和大家一起探讨一期非常深入、甚至可以说是有趣且迷人的节目，关于内向者和外向者的区别。或者我或许该说，你们认为的区别是什么，但我们可能由于人类个性的过度简单化而被误导了。外向性和内向性似乎成了分裂社会的奇怪事物。谁是社交达人？谁是隐士？
But it is so much more complex and nuanced than that. You know, I consider myself an extrovert, but I don't really party. I cancel plans probably way more than I should. I feel tired a lot. So maybe I'm an introvert. You know, there's all these like different ways of seeing it. and I really want to explore what it actually means. And, you know, I also have friends who are most certainly introverts,
但它远比这更复杂、更微妙。你知道，我认为自己是个外向的人，但我并不怎么参加派对。我取消计划的频率可能远远超过我应该做的。我经常感到疲惫。所以也许我是个内向的人。你知道，看待这个问题有各种各样不同的方式。我真的很想探讨它真正的含义。而且，你知道，我也有一些绝对是内向的朋友，
who really need a lot of alone time, but, you know, for the two hours that they're at the party, like they are the life of the party. Basically, what I'm trying to say is that it's complicated. And what I really want to do is break down the origin of this concept, like historically in the psychology community, what the research really tells us about each personality. type and why that simple version that we probably all know is is incorrect. We're going to start at the
他们真的很需要很多独处时间，但是，你知道，在派对上的那两个小时里，他们就像是派对的灵魂。基本上，我想说的是，情况很复杂。我真正想做的是剖析这个概念的起源，比如在心理学界历史上的起源，研究到底告诉了我们关于每种人格类型的什么信息，以及为什么我们可能都熟知的那个简单版本是不正确的。我们要从
very beginning and then explore how levels of extroversion and introversion have maybe even changed in recent years, more specifically how it differs within individuals based on factors like gender and culture. I also want to discuss the myth to do with so-called ambivers. Why do you feel that you might not be either an introvert or extrovert and is the term ambivert appropriate. But ultimately, what is it that makes us more like one than the other, scientifically? And I also want to finish out the conversation by talking about how we can accept the introverted or extroverted part of ourselves, especially in a world, you know, in a career, in a friendship, maybe even an environment where certain parts of being an introvert or being an extrovert don't feel
最开始讲起，然后探讨外向和内向的程度近年来是否甚至发生了变化，更具体地说，它在不同个体之间如何因性别和文化等因素而有所不同。我还想讨论与所谓“中间性格者”（ambiverts）有关的迷思。为什么你会觉得你既不是内向也不是外向，以及“中间性格者”这个词是否合适。但归根结底，从科学角度来看，是什么让我们更倾向于其中一种而不是另一种？我还想通过讨论我们如何在生活中——尤其是在一个某些内向或外向特征感觉不被接受的世界、职业、友谊甚至环境中——接纳自己内向或外向的那一面，来为这次对话画上句号。所以有很多内容要涵盖。如果你和我一样，对，你知道的，对一般的人格真的很着迷，这绝对是能让你大开眼界并为你提供一些你可能不知道的酷知识的一期节目。我希望你准备好了。我绝对准备好了。闲话少说，我要让我的病嗓休息一小会儿，
accepted. So there is a lot to cover. If you are like me and really fascinated by, you know, just personality in general, this is definitely the episode to open your eyes and give you some cool facts that you may not have known. I hope you're ready. I am definitely ready. Without further ado, I'm going to give you a short break from my sick voice.
然后进入本期节目，探讨内向者和外向者之间的心理差异以及可能的相似之处。我们开始吧。我想直接切入正题，谈谈内向者和外向者之间的主要区别，其中一些我们可能已经很熟悉了，还有一些你可能没听过。但在那之前，我们确实需要知道这个想法是从哪里来的。我觉得内向、外向这些词现在已经成了我们共同语言的一部分，就像它们是我们随口乱用的心理学术语一样，我们可以左右逢源地把它们塞进对话中，但我确实认为了解它们是如何诞生的也非常重要。这是一个重要的部分，你知道，哪怕只是作为冷知识也好，
and get into the episode, get into the psychological differences and perhaps similarities between introverts and extroverts. Let's get into it. I want to get straight into it and talk about the major differences between introverts and extroverts, some of which we're probably already familiar with, some others of which you may not have heard of. But before that, we do need to know where this idea came from. I feel like these terms of... introvert extrovert have become parts of our shared language now like they're parts of the psycho babble we throw them into conversations left right and center but I do think it's really important to also know how they came to be it's an important piece you know even if trivia
所以为了解释这些概念，你真正需要了解的人是卡尔·容格（Carl Jung），他是位传奇的瑞士精神分析学家和精神科医生。他很有名。他可以归功于比我能数得过来的还要多的概念，而外向和内向只是其中之一。他基本上将这些视为我们每个人格的核心特征，你知道，我们可以用它来对社会中的人进行分类并对他们的人格进行分类。要么内向程度高，要么外向程度高。不过，我们很多人其实都搞错的一点是，你必须一直明确地是其中一种或另一种——根据容格的观点，这是不对的，我们其实都有外向和内向
if nothing else so the person you really want to know about in order to explain these concepts is Carl Jung he is a legendary Swiss psychoanalyst and psychiatrist he He is famous. He can be credited with more concepts than I think I could even count. And extroversion and introvert is just one of them. He basically saw these as central traits to each of our personalities and, you know, something that we could use to categorize people in society and categorize their personalities. You were either high in introversion or high in extroversion. something that a lot of us actually get wrong though is that you have to be one or the other explicitly at all times not true according to yung we actually all have an extroverted and introverted
的一面，只是其中一面在更多时候更具主导地位。说实话，你知道，我其实从来没有遇到过完全百分之百内向或完全外向的人。你知道，也许唯一的例子，我当时在想这个，然后我想：不，一定有这样的人。我能想到的唯一例子就是那个在岛上独自生活了20年的哲学家，我完全忘记他的名字了。如果你知道他是谁，请留个言，因为这会让我很恼火。但是，你知道，也许我们能归类为
side one is just more dominant more of the time and to be honest you know i have never actually met somebody who is entirely 100% introverted or entirely extroverted. You know, maybe the only example, like I was thinking about this and I was like, no, there must be someone. The only example I can think of is like that philosopher who lived on an island by himself for 20 years, I've completely forgotten his name. If you know who it is, leave a comment because it's going to annoy me. But, you know, perhaps the only people who we could accredit as being.
百分之百偏向某一端的人是所谓的隐士，也就是离群索居的人。但同样，那是极其极其罕见的。而且，你知道，并不是说你只能从我们自己身上获取能量，或者你只能从他人身上获取能量。人类需要不同的东西，不同的燃料来源，不同的动机和能量来源。这其实是外向者和内向者之间最重要的区别。它取决于我们各自更喜欢如何获取能量或充电。我们是从自己内心还是从外部世界寻求灵感和刺激？
100% one over the other are people who are so-called hermits, people who are socially reclusive. But again, that is very, very rare. And, you know, it's not the case that you can only receive energy from ourselves or you can only receive energy from others. Humans require different things, different sources of fuel, different sources of motivation and energy. This here is actually the most important distinction between an extrovert and an introvert. It rests on how we each prefer to gain energy or recharge. Do we seek inspiration and stimulation from within ourselves or out in the world?
这是我们所有人都身处其中的一个光谱，而我们所处的位置其实每天都在变化，但我们确实往往更倾向于某一方。现在，那些正好坐在中间的人，被称为中间性格者（ambiverts）。有些人会说，他们拥有完美平衡的外向和内向特征或渴望。实际上值得注意的是，这种中间性格者的想法其实是对最初理论的现代补充。所以容格本人并没有引入这个术语。他不认为中间性格者存在。所以，当然，他也不会给它起名字。
It's a spectrum that we all sit on and where we sit can actually change day to day, but we do tend to lean more one way than the other. Now, people who sit right in the middle, they're known as ambivorts. They have a perfect balance, some would say, of extroverted and introverted traits or desires. It's actually important to note that this idea of an ambivert is actually a modern addition to the original theory. So Jung, he himself did not introduce that term. He didn't believe that ambivorts existed. So, of course, he wouldn't have given it a name.
他确实说过，你两者兼有，但其中一个占主导地位。因此，没有人是中间性格者，因为那将暗示一种完全的平衡，两者的完美统一或融合。无论如何，基本上，是什么让你成为内向者还是外向者，取决于你主要从哪里寻求满足感或刺激。所以一个主要外向的人从人际互动中寻求这一点。因此就有了这种看法：他们相当健谈，是社交达人，有很多朋友，他们制定计划，他们充满热情，他们真正从他人的能量或群体中获得蓬勃发展。相比之下，我们认为内向的人则从独自活动中
He really did say, you have both, but one is dominant. Therefore, no one is an ambivirte, because that would suggest a complete balance, a perfect unison or blend of them both. Anyways, basically, what makes you an introvert versus an extrovert depends on where you primarily seek gratification or stimulation. So a primarily extroverted person seeks it from human interaction. Hence this idea that they're quite talkative, they're social butterflies, they have many friends, they make plans, they're enthusiastic, they really thrive from the energy of others or in a group. In contrast, people we would consider introverts derive gratification and peace from solo
获得满足和平静，从他们如此渴望的独处时间中获得。他们稍微保守一些、安静一些、也许被动一些。如果你是个内向的人，你可能也会发现，如果你和人在一起的时间太长，连续好几天都是如此，你确实会变得有点烦躁，无法集中注意力。你只想融入背景中，迫不及待地想回到你的房间，回到你的空间，回到那个你可以做自己的地方。在自己的陪伴中。相比之下，外向的人可能永远不想让派对停止。就像，他们是那种会说：好吧，主活动结束了，
activities from that alone time that they crave so much. They're a bit more reserved, quiet, passive maybe. If you're an introvert, you may also find that if you have been around people for too long, for too many days in a row, you do get a bit irritated, you can't focus. You want to just kind of fade into the background and you can't wait to like get back to your room, get back to your space, get back to a place where you can just be. in your own company. In comparison, like, an extrovert may never want the party to stop. Like, they're the ones who are like, okay, like, we finish the main event.
来我这里玩吧。去看电影吧。我们出去再喝一杯吧。他们是一天中真正需要多个社交接触点的人。所以他们早上需要见某人。他们晚上需要和某人通话。你知道，他们喜欢有一个满满当当的社交日历，并且他们会发觉，如果连续好几天看不到人，或者没有进行真正滋养心灵的对话或互动，他们就会感到不那么满足、不那么有目标感、不那么有创造力、不那么充实。
Come hang out at my place. Like, let's go watch a movie. Let's go out for another drink. They're people who really need multiple social touch points throughout the day. So they need to see someone in the morning. They need to have a call with someone in the evening. You know, they like to have a full social calendar. and they will find that they feel less satisfied, less purposeful, less creative, less fulfilled
不过，有些内向的人确实有——我不知道该用什么词，但姑且叫内向的朋友吧。我们就这么叫他们。那些他们可以一直待在一起、并且不需要为了恢复精力而抽离休息的人。通常那是另一个内向的人，对吧？那是你可以与之一同度过我们所谓的“平行时间”的人，你们就像是都坐在同一个房间里，但做着不同的事情，不过你们享受彼此的实体陪伴。这是一个小警示，是对内向天性的一点小补充。一些心理学家提出，内向者的能量往往会在反思中膨胀，
when they go too many days without seeing people or really like having nourishing conversations or interactions. Some introverts though do have like, I don't know what the term is, but like introverted pals. Let's call them that. People who they can be around constantly and not feel the need to have a break from in order to restore their energy. normally it's another introvert right it's someone who you can do what we call parallel time with where you're like both sitting in the same room but you're doing different things but you enjoy like the physical presence that's a a little caveat a little small addition to the introverted nature some psychologists have suggested that introverts are people whose energy tends to expand
而在互动中缩减，但那是积极的互动。所以，如果这种互动不会耗尽他们所有的心理资源，他们也可以和其他人呆在一起。他们可以保持沉默。他们可以思考。他们可以进行内省。现在，内向并不等同于反社交、害羞、甚至有社交焦虑。这是一个常见的误解，但外向者也可以和日常内向者一样害羞，一样有社交焦虑。我本人就是一个极其外向的人。事实上，你知道，我最近刚刚被提醒了这一点。比如，我连续好几天没见任何人，我确实感觉情绪低落。我感到情绪明显低落。但我也经历过不少
through reflection and dwindle during interaction but active interaction. So they can be around other people if it is not something that is going to cost them all their mental resources. They can be silent. They can be thinking. They can be introspecting. Now, introversion is not the same thing as being antisocial or shy or even having social anxiety. It's a common misconception, but extroverts can be just as shy and just as socially anxious as your everyday introvert. I am somebody, again, who was incredibly extroverted. In fact, you know, I was reminded of that fact very recently. Like, I spent a few days in a row without seeing anyone, and I did feel low. I felt a significant dip in my mood. But I also have my fair share of
感到尴尬的时刻，感觉自己不应该去参加某个活动。我不认识任何人。我并非无时无刻都自信满满，因为外向性和社交能力或人们认为的社会接纳度并不是一回事。这是个性的另一个方面。如果我们从另一个角度来看，内向的人也可以是你认识的最自信、最确信自己的人，这与人们的想象相反。他们只是在一天中需要更多属于自己的空间。但你可以把他们放在一个大舞台、一个大群体面前，
moments of feeling awkward, of feeling like I shouldn't go to this thing. I don't know anyone. I'm not confident all the time because extroversion and social ability or perceived social acceptance are not the same thing. This is a whole other facet of personality. If we look at it another way, an introvert can be the most confident, self-assured person you know, counter to what people may think. They just need more space in their day for themselves. But you could put them in front of a big crowd, in a big group, And they would still feel at ease.
他们依然会感到自在。只是这不是他们寻求认可、满足和能量的首选方式。再说一次，这是两个不同的维度。所以继续这堂历史课，在卡尔·容格近100年前首次在一篇著作中提出这个想法之后，它随后被该领域的许多其他人所采纳。许多其他心理学家和精神科医生觉得：嗯，他可能是对的，
It's just that it's not their preferred way to seek validation, gratification, and energy. Again, it's two different dimensions. So continuing on with this history lesson, after Kau Yong first introduced this idea and a piece of writing almost 100 years ago, it was then adopted by many others in the field. Many other psychologists and psychiatrists were like, huh, he might be. might be right and they wrote papers finding things that were very very similar to what he was noting that we could identify people in this way and so extroversion slash introversion became what we now know as one of the defining personality traits that we use today famously it is now part of what we call
他们撰写了论文，发现了与他所注意到的非常非常相似的东西，即我们可以用这种方式识别人们，因此外向/内向成为了我们今天所知的决定性人格特征之一。众现在，它已经是我们所说的“大五人格”的一部分了。我们以前多次讨论过大五人格，如果你是心理学专业学生，我相信你以前听过很多很多次了。所以很抱歉显得无聊。但我们不妨把它当作一次复习。如果你对这个概念还很陌生，大五人格基本上是心理学家试图通过将我们的人格分类来对我们人类进行分类的一种尝试。
the big five now we've spoken about the big five many times before and if you're a psychology student I'm sure you have heard of this before many, many times. So apologies for being boring. But let's just consider this a refresher. If you're new to the idea, the Big Five is basically the attempt of psychologist to categorize us as humans by categorizing our personalities. It's basically the closest thing that we have to a formula for describing someone based on five core traits and where they sit on this spectrum of, these traits. So consider like five scales and you can sit, you know, in different positions on each of those scales. And where you sit on those different positions will end up giving you your
它基本上是我们拥有的最接近根据五个核心特征及其在这个光谱上的位置来描述某人的公式的东西。所以可以把它想象成五个刻度，你可以坐在这些刻度的不同位置上。你在这些不同位置上的坐落最终会赋予你你的人格类型。如果你做过迈尔斯-布里格斯测试，你就会对此非常非常熟悉。我们来谈谈这些特征。首先是对经验的开放性。所以你要么是一个非常好奇、非常有创造力、非常非常非常、但是。
personality type. If you've ever done, you know, the Myers-Briggs test, like you'll be very, very familiar with this. Let's talk about the traits. So the first one is openness to experiences. So you can either be someone who is very curious, very, very, very, very, very, very, but. And so, you can either be someone. creative, is really accepting of new things, is really hungering for new sensations, maybe takes risks, is happy with the discomfort of experiencing something new, or you can be someone who is quite happy in the normalcy and happy in the comfort of their routine. Next, we have conscientiousness. This is organization, how efficient you are, your general sense of responsibility. You can be someone who we would call quite type A.
所以，你可以是一个富有创造力、非常接受新事物、极度渴望新感觉、可能会冒风险、对体验新事物的痛苦感到高兴的人，或者你也可以是一个对常规感到相当高兴、在日常生活的舒适中感到快乐的人。接下来是尽责性。这是组织能力、你的效率、你的普遍责任感。你可以是一个我们称之为A型人格的人。非常高效、非常有条理、非常多产。或者你也可以是一个有点随性、比较随波逐流的人。
It was very efficient, very organized, very productive. Or you can be someone who kind of, you know, operates more by like the seat of their pants is a little bit more on the go. Then we have extraversion, which we've already talked about. One side of the scale is extraversion. The other one is introversion. Are you social? Are you assertive?
然后是外向性，我们已经讨论过了。刻度的一端是外向。另一端是内向。你善于社交吗？你自信吗？还是你更保守？你从反思中获取能量。然后是宜人性。这是同情心、尊重、对他人的信任，基本上就是你与人相处的能力。我们都知道有些人生来就是“点火者”。他们只会制造冲突。然后还有另一群人，
Or are you more reserved? You gain energy from reflection. Then we have agreeableness. There's this is compassion, respectfulness, trust in others, basically your ability to get along. We all know there are people who like, they just start fires. They just create conflict. And then there's another set of people who are very, I don't know what the word is, but they're just very easy to be around.
我不知道该用什么词，但他们就是非常容易相处。他们其实不想争论。并不是说他们没有意见，但他们懂得看场合。他们就是那种人缘很好的人。最后是神经质。所以这可能是我们谈论心理健康的最大的领域。这是其中很小的一部分。但你倾向于相当焦虑和抑郁，或者，是的，他们过去常用来形容它的词——相当神经质？还是你是一个没有真正被这些事情困扰的人？
They don't really want to disagree. It's not that they don't have opinions, but they know the time and place. Like, they're just an everybody person. Then finally we have neuroticism. So this is probably the biggest area where we would talk about mental health. It's a very slim part of it. But do you lean towards being quite anxious and depressed or, yeah, quite neurotic is the term they used to use for it? Or are you someone who was not really afflicted by those things?
所以个人的人格被认为具备所有这些特点。我们所有人都坐在刻度的某处。你不可能在任何一项上得零分。你坐在某个位置。所以你可能外向性很高，但对新体验的开放性很低。所以你喜欢你喜欢的人，但你发现很难向新朋友敞开心扉。你也可能外向性很低，所以你是个内向的人，但宜人性很高，神经质很低。所以你给人的印象非常友好和开放，但这并不一定意味着你一直想和人呆在一起。
So individual personalities are thought to feature each of these. Like all of us sit somewhere on the scale. You can't be like zero in any of these. Like you sit somewhere. So you can rate high in extroversion, but low in openness to new experiences. So you like the people you like, but you find it hard to open up to new friends. You may also be low in extroversion, so you're an introvert, but high in agreeableness and low on neuroticism. So you come off as really friendly and open, but that doesn't necessarily mean that you want to be around people all the time.
基本上，我想让你从大五人格中得出的结论是，人格比内向与外向要宏大得多。而且它绝对比大五人格还要宏大。大五人格是一个很好的结构，可以解释某人在特定情况下可能会如何反应，为什么他们会是现在这样。但它不包括诸如兴趣、特定爱好、激情、我们的自我概念、我们的自我概念——我们如何看待自己。这其实是人们发现大五人格的一个巨大缺陷。它没有真正解释这一点。它没有解释，你知道，我们对自己的看法，它只解释了我们如何在他人面前显得怎样。但人格，你知道，
Basically, what I want you to conclude from the big five is that personality is, bigger than introversion versus extroversion. And it's also most certainly bigger than the big five. The big five is a great structure to explain how someone might react in a certain situation, why they are the way they are. But it doesn't include things like interests, specific hobbies, passions, our self-concept, our self-concept, how we think about ourselves. That's actually a big floor that people find with the big five. It's that it doesn't really explain this. It doesn't explain, you know, our perspective on ourselves, it just explains how we may appear to others. But personality, you know, it is also a requirement to describe personality that we reflect on our own emotional
描述人格也是一个要求，即我们要反思我们自己的情感模式、某些能力、行为、喜好、厌恶。此类例子不胜枚举。这就是为什么我真的警告人们不要认为自己要么完全内向要么完全外向，更不要错误地认为它完全定义了你，因为我向这保证它绝对没有，它只是其中一个组成部分。从那以后继续，我想回答一个具体的问题，我们在本节目的前半部分基本忽略了这个问题。是什么真正让一个人内向与外向？
patterns, our certain abilities, our behaviors, our likes, our dislikes. Like the list goes on. And that's why I really warn people against thinking about themselves as either entirely introverted or entirely extroverted, and more than that, wrongly assuming that it defines who you are in its entirety, because I promise it doesn't, it's just one component. So moving on from that, I want to answer a specific question now that we have largely ignored for the first part of this episode. What actually makes someone introverted versus extroverted? Like, is it something that we just pop out of the womb being? Like, is it like a weird Harry Potter sorting hat?
就像，这是我们从娘胎里生下来就自带的吗？就像一个奇怪的哈利波特分院帽吗？是什么造就了我们？所以当然有一些解释。在心理学中，事情从来都不是直截了当的。首先是它在很大程度上（但并非全部）是遗传的。所以有一个巨大的基因成分，我们可以在双胞胎研究中看到这一点。在2020年进行的一系列双胞胎研究中，研究人员观察了600多组不同的基因，发现蓝图，
What makes us who we are? So there are a few explanations, of course. It's never straightforward in psychology. The first is that it's largely, but not entirely inherited. So there's a huge genetic component, and we can see that in twin studies. In one series of twin studies conducted in 2020, Researchers looked at more than 600 different genes and found that blueprint, genetic blueprint, contributed somewhere between 30 to 60% to whether you were extroverted or introverted.
即基因蓝图，对你是外向还是内向贡献了大约30%到60%的比例。所以基本上，如果你有一个外向的父母或者你有一个外向的双胞胎，你大约有30%到60%的概率也是外向的，而不是内向的。所以这就是遗传率。如果我们带上一百万个人，在相同情况下，其中会有多少人最终成为外向者？会有多少人走向另一个极端成为内向者？老实说，你知道，如果它处于30%的低端，在我的眼里其实是相当微不足道的。但，你知道，它总比没有强。
So basically, if you had an extroverted parent or you had an extroverted twin, there was around a 30 to 60% chance that you would also be extroverted, not introverted. So that is like heritability. What's the likelihood that if we took a million people, how many of them in the same circumstances would end up as extroverts? How many of them would go the other way and end up as introverts? Honestly, you know, if it's at the low end of like 30%, that's actually pretty minimal in my eyes. But, you know, it's bigger than nothing. And it still does point to the fact that who your parents are really does influence who you will be.
而且它仍然指向这样一个事实：你的父母是谁确实会影响你将成为什么样的人。基因之所以有影响，是因为基因如何影响我们大脑中某些系统的运作。所以我们都知道，当我们获得基因蓝图时，该基因蓝图会影响很多事情。它影响的事情之一就是大脑的发育。这就是让接下来的两个理论变得重要的原因。一个重要的理论是，你究竟是外向还是内向，归结为一个真正的唤醒水平，我们谈论的不是性唤醒，而是我们的身体和心灵对刺激的警觉和准备程度。
So the reason that genetics has an influence is because of how genetics can influence how certain systems in our brain work. So we all know that when we get a genetic blueprint, that genetic blueprint influences a lot of things. One of the things that it influences is cerebral or brain development. And that's what makes the next two theories important. A big theory is that whether you are an extrovert or an introvert comes down to a real. arousal, and we're not talking about sexual arousal, but the extent to which our bodies and our minds are alert and ready to stimulation. So this explanation was first proposed way back in the 1960s, and basically it suggested that the brains of extroverts are chronically under aroused,
这个解释最早在20世纪60年代提出，基本上它表明外向者的脑长期处于低唤醒状态，导致他们从环境中寻求刺激。外向者需要，基本上需要付出更多努力来使自己达到其他人认为正常和愉快的水平。因此，为什么他们真的很喜欢新奇的社交体验。他们喜欢和人呆在一起。他们甚至可能更加喧闹、喜欢冒险。相比之下，内向者的自然阈值已经较低。
leading them to seek out stimulation from the environment. Extroverts need to, to basically work harder to get themselves up to the level that others find normal and pleasant. Hence why they really like novel social experiences. They like being around people. They may even be more boisterous and risk-taking. In contrast, introverts already have a naturally lower threshold. So it takes less for them to feel kind of overstimulated. You know, a really good book, a movie night, that provides just as much stimulation and fun to them as a club because they don't need as much to bring about enjoyment.
所以他们感觉被过度刺激所需的条件更少。你知道，一本好书、一个电影之夜，对他们来说提供的刺激和乐趣和一个俱乐部一样多，因为他们不需要太多的东西就能带来快乐。而过多的刺激实际上会让他们感到不知所措，而对于外向者来说，有时候极限是不存在的。所以真的，这一切归根结底的建议是，我们的大脑及其内部运作，特别是多巴胺、血清素、肾上腺素或去甲肾上腺素等神经递质的活动。
And too much stimulation actually makes them quite overwhelmed, whereas for extroverts, sometimes the limit doesn't exist. So really, what this all comes down to, this is a suggestion, is our brains and their inner workings. specifically the activity of neurotransmitters like dopamine, serotonin, adrenaline or norapine. Now, this theory of arousal was presented almost 60 years ago, and since then we have obviously become a lot more advanced in our scientific technologies, so we've been able to test what was once a bit of a wild guess. Turns out it was a pretty good guess. In 2005, researchers from the University of Amsterdam set out to test this theory specifically by looking at whether extroversion versus introversion is really determined by how active our dopamine systems are. Now, a lot of us think
现在，这个唤醒理论是在近60年前提出的，从那以后，我们的科学技术显然取得了更大的进步，所以我们能够测试曾经只是盲目猜测的东西。事实证明，这是一个相当不错的猜测。2005年，阿姆斯特丹大学的研究人员着手通过观察外向性与内向性是否真的由我们的多巴胺系统的活跃程度决定，来专门测试这个理论。现在，我们很多人认为多巴胺是快乐化学物质。这是真的，但它也负责动机、学习、集中注意力、社交能力。所以它将在这种人格特质中发挥作用。
of dopamine as the happy chemical. That's true, but it's also responsible for motivation, learning, concentration, social ability. So it's going to play a role in this personality trait. They got a huge sample of people and they grouped them based on a simple personality. test and then they got them to participate in a game of sorts where they had to place bets and they had to be, it was in like a social environment and they were either rewarded for their gamble or not. Here's what they saw. The reward centres of the brain displayed a lot more activity when the individual was an extrovert. They also paid attention to the game for longer. They seemed more keen to keep engaging in the game, maybe because of that social element. But all of this, this whole
他们获得了一个庞大的样本，并根据一个简单的性格测试将他们分组，然后让他们参与一种游戏，他们必须下注，而且是在一个社交环境中进行，无论他们的赌博是否受到奖励，他们都会得到奖励。以下是他们所看到的。当个体是外向者时，大脑的奖赏中心表现出更多的活动。他们还更长时间地关注游戏。他们似乎更热衷于继续参与游戏，也许是因为那种社交元素。但所有这一切，整个经历，他们从中获得了更积极、更有回报的反应。
experience, they were receiving a more positive, more rewarding reaction from it. The introverts, on the other hand, or who the scientists imagined were introverts based on this personality test, they displayed a whole lot less activity in those same areas, suggesting that extroverts are the way they are because they just have a high, heightened sensitivity to reward, highly reactive dopamine systems, and they already receive a baseline of reward just from being around people that introverts don't get. So it makes sense that these people would be happier in big social situations or taking social risks or even personal risks because of what happens deep in their brains. That's one side of the coin, but it also comes down to
相比之下，内向者——或者科学家根据这个性格测试想象为内向者的人——在这些相同的区域表现出的活动要少得多，这表明外向者之所以是现在的样子，是因为他们对奖赏有着高度敏感、高度反应的多巴胺系统，并且他们仅仅通过和内向者没有获得的人呆在一起，就已经获得了奖赏的基准线。所以这些人如果在大的社交场合中，或者承担社交风险甚至是个人风险时会更快乐，这是合乎情理的，因为他们的大脑深处发生了这样的事情。这是硬币的一面，
environment, specifically culture, socialization, how we were raised, and that's one further piece of the puzzle that we were going to explore after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, research, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world
但它也归结为环境，特别是文化、社会化、我们是如何被抚养长大的，那是我们在短暂休息后将探讨的拼图的又一个部分。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，建立精神坚韧、体能和韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-E. That's T-E. BW0% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。那是 T-E。那是 T-E。BW0%，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上拍打小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode
乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时准备谈论霹雳可卡因，但为了让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是第二集
where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history.
我们讨论霹雳可卡因了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的，我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，主持人是我，你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we're, We don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中了，以至于我们，我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了样东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，
hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
你是一个好人，因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity（亲子关系）丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭示了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。艾伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. that Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县宣布劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。说相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这一季的新《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Looking at the origin behind introversion and extroversion, specifically like the biological underpinnings, is one thing. But humans, I don't think, can be reduced to chemical messages in their brain. I think doing so miss is a really important part of the picture. And that part we miss comes down to so. social influence and environment. It seems that where you were born and where you grow up will also determine whether you are more extroverted versus introverted. If you grow up within a culture
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。审视内向和外向背后的起源，特别是生物学基础，是一回事。但我认为，人类不能被简化为大脑中的化学信息。我认为这样做错过了一个非常重要的图景。而我们错过的那个部分归结为社交影响和环境。似乎你出生的地方和成长的地方也将决定你是更外向还是更内向。如果你在某种文化中长大
that values outward social engagement and being outgoing and loud and very forward, extroversion rates will seemingly be higher because more people learn that this is what is what is kind of expected of them. They're also kind of raised to adapt to these environments. They mimic the behaviors of those around them. So they may appear to be more extroverted. When we compare that to quite reflective, peaceful societies where children are taught and raised to be quiet, to be reserved, to be introspective, we're definitely going to see a difference in overall rates. Consider the difference, for example, between individuals from a country like Japan versus the United States. Obviously, not everyone within those countries are going to be the same. You know, no one group is
那种重视外向的社会交往、表现得外向、声音洪亮且非常积极进取的文化，外向性格的比例似乎就会更高，因为更多的人了解到这就是别人对他们的期待。他们也是在这样的环境中被抚养长大的。他们模仿周围人的行为。所以他们可能显得更加外向。当我们把这种情况与那些沉思、平静的社会进行对比时——在这些社会中，孩子们被教育和培养要安静、矜持、内省——我们肯定会看到整体比例上的差异。例如，试想一下日本与美国这两个国家的人之间的差异。很明显，并非这些国家中的每个人都完全相同。你知道的，没有任何一个群体是
completely homogenous. But if we took the median of each, I would expect the US to be higher in extroversion and the Japanese people higher in introversion. So the research shows that level levels of extraversion seem to be divided by whether a country or a culture is actually individualistic or collectivist. So individualistic cultures like the United States, they prioritize individual expression and outward displays of confidence. That's linked to extroversion. Collectivist cultures, on the other hand, they value harmony, they value group cohesion. That might lead to more introverted behaviors. You know, I would love to see, like, at what point being removed from that culture in place in the other one would maybe change who you are? Like, if you grew up in the United
完全同质化的。但如果我们取两者的中位数，我预计美国的外向程度会更高，而日本人的内向程度会更高。因此研究表明，外向程度的高低似乎取决于一个国家或文化究竟是个人主义的还是集体主义的。因此像美国这样的个人主义文化，它们优先考虑个人表达和对外展现自信。这与外向性息息相关。另一方面，集体主义文化则重视和谐，重视群体凝聚力。这可能会导致更多内向的行为。你知道的，我很想知道，一个人在什么时间点脱离那种文化并置身于另一种文化中，可能会改变你是谁？比如，如果你在美国长大
States until you were six and then you moved to a place like Japan, would that change who you are? Or, like, would it have to be when you were three? Could it be, you know, as late as 15? It would just be very, very cool. Like, whether it would be a really great way to. to see whether it's something you're born with or something that you learn. Like if there's a certain direction you're going that's then like completely turned around by primarily exposure to a different culture. A long ramble. Apologies.
直到六岁，然后搬到了像日本这样的地方，这会改变你是谁吗？或者说，必须在三岁的时候吗？难道甚至可以迟到15岁吗？那将是非常非常酷的事情。这会是一个非常棒的方法，去看看这究竟是与生俱来的东西，还是后天学习得来的。比如，如果你原本正朝着某个方向前进，然后由于主要接触了不同的文化而完全逆转了方向。扯得有点远了，抱歉。
I'm just very interested in that. Like it would be cool research project. Gender also influences us a whole lot because it impacts how people choose to see us and how we are raised. I feel like I don't have to do a whole revision or history lesson, but you know, know, there's this real sense that loudness in young girls is definitely policed. It isn't seen as attractive. Whereas for young boys, like, it's totally acceptable. They are raised to be boisterous, loud, a lot more social.
我只是对这个非常感兴趣。感觉会是一个很酷的研究项目。性别也极大地影响着我们，因为它影响着别人如何看待我们以及我们是如何被抚养长大的。我觉得我不需要长篇大论地复习历史，但是你知道的，确实有一种强烈的观念：年轻女孩如果声音洪亮，绝对会受到规训。这不被认为是具有吸引力的。然而对于小男孩来说，这完全是可以接受的。他们被培养成精力充沛、声音洪亮、社交能力更强的人。
So there are actually higher rates of introversion amongst women compared to men. It also kind of brings me to a crucial question of this episode, maybe one that you are asking yourself at this point. you know, if you were raised in a specific culture, if you were raised as a woman to be quite timid, to be quite shy, to be quite silent, can we change that the older we get? Is there an opportunity at some point to become more extroverted or is it forever more a permanent part of our identity? I think from my research and also experiences, it is really possible for us to obviously momentarily slip into an introverted or extroverted state if our environment requires it, sometimes even
所以女性之中的内向比例实际上比男性更高。这也让我想到了本期节目的一个关键问题，也许这也是你此刻正在自问的问题：你知道的，如果你是在特定的文化中长大的，如果你作为一个女性被培养成相当胆小、相当害羞、相当沉默的人，随着我们年龄的增长，我们能改变这一点吗？在某个时刻，我们是否有机会变得更加外向，还是说这永远是我们身份中不可磨灭的一部分？我认为从我的研究以及经历来看，如果我们的环境需要的话，我们显然完全有可能暂时转入内向或外向的状态，有时甚至
for more than a moment. Obviously, we were discussing before Jung's theory that actually it's just that one is more dominant, but you do still have introverted and extroverted parts, and when it's appropriate, that part of you might switch on. I've heard stories from friends, but also in case studies of people who after trauma, especially a social kind of trauma, they were extroverts and they become introverted. They no longer get the same energy. We also see people who are quite introverted who enter a new environment, perhaps a new workplace or a new relationship and become quite extroverted. But if you do believe the psychology and the personality theories, what they say is that you should always return back to the state that is natural.
不止是一会儿。显然，我们之前讨论过荣格的理论，即实际上只是其中一种性格更为占据主导，但你身上依然同时具备内向和外向的部分，而在合适的时候，你身上的那一部分可能会被激活。我听过朋友们的故事，在一些案例研究中也看到过，有些人经历创伤后，特别是某种社交创伤，他们原本是外向的人，却变得内向了。他们再也无法获得同样的能量。我们也会看到一些相当内向的人，在进入一个新环境（也许是一个新职场或一段新感情）后变得相当外向。但如果你相信心理学和人格理论，它们的说法是：你最终总是会回归到那种对你而言最自然的
for you, even when the trauma has hopefully been addressed, even when you're in that workplace that demands this from you, at some point your true nature is going to come out and you're going to return to what we call like emotional or I guess even social homeostasis. I think beyond that, though, people do change as they get older and as their situation changes as well. So yes, it might be a momentary lapse into introversion or extroversion, but over time, if a situation demands it, or if you just change as you grow, you will see that you're skewing perhaps more towards the other direction. You know, consider someone who is really isolated in a retirement home. Maybe they become more introverted out of necessity. You know, it's quite a sad example,
状态，哪怕创伤有望得到解决，哪怕你身处那个对你提出这种要求的职场，在某个时刻，你的本性还是会显露出来，你会回归到我们所谓的生理平衡，或者我想甚至是社交平衡。我认为除此之外，随着人们年龄的增长以及处境的改变，人们确实会发生改变。所以是的，这可能只是短暂地陷入内向或外向，但随着时间推移，如果形势需要，或者随着你的成长而发生改变，你会发现自己可能更倾向于另一个方向。你知道的，想想那些在养老院里真正被孤立的人。也许由于必需，他们变得更内向了。你知道的，这是一个相当悲哀的例子，
but in the state, like, it's harder for them to change their name. entirely. So maybe this part of them just becomes more present. It means that they are forced to be okay with being alone because of their situation. And so maybe some small part of them adapts to that. What we're really wanting to discuss here is can we change our personality? Like that's the real key question of the hour. And I actually have an interview coming out with someone in two weeks and it's this amazing author from the Atlantic and she tried to to change her personality over the span of a year and she was really, really diligent. She enacted all of these lifestyle changes and habits and she did find some great success.
但在这种状态下，要想彻底改变他们的名字要难得多。所以也许他们身上的这部分变得更加明显了。这意味着由于他们的处境，他们被迫习惯并接受孤独。因此，也许他们身上的一小部分会适应这种状况。我们在这里真正想讨论的是，我们能改变自己的人格吗？这才是当下真正核心的问题。其实我两周后将要发布一个采访，采访对象是《大西洋月刊》的一位了不起的作家，她尝试在一年时间里改变自己的人格，而且她真的非常非常努力。她做出了所有这些生活方式的改变和习惯的调整，并且确实取得了一些巨大的成功。
So I'm not going to spoil that episode. But yeah, I do think that persistent intervention on major lifestyle events can permanently shift you. Even though like there is a theory that you'll always come back, I think depending on the magnitude of the event or how intense. and diligent you are with your exercises to become more introverted or more extroverted, I do think it can work. But what I would ask is, why would you want to? You know, if I'm talking about this and you are really paying attention, why is it that you feel like it's so necessary for you to change who you may fundamentally be?
所以我不会剧透那一期节目。但是是的，我确实认为对重大生活事件的持续干预可以永久地改变你。尽管有一种理论认为你最终总会回归本性，但我认为取决于事件的规模，或者你在进行旨在变得更内向或更外向的练习时是多么的强烈和刻苦，我确实认为这是行得通的。不过我要问的是，你为什么要这么做呢？你知道的，如果我正在谈论这些而你听得很认真，为什么你会觉得去改变你可能原本的自我会是如此必要？
If this is who you are and where your energy levels, your social, levels, your stimulation levels naturally sit, what would push you to try and strongly change that part of you? I think I have an answer, right? I think it really does come down to the fact that it often feels like society is made for a very specific type or level of extrovert, not someone who was introverted and definitely not someone who was too extroverted. And I actually received a message from a listener about this, which really inspired me to do this topic where she was talking about how difficult it is to feel like you'll be successful when you are naturally quieter or naturally less assertive or naturally less interested in networking in a world where all our depictions of
如果这就是你，这就是你的能量水平、你的社交水平、你的刺激水平自然安放的地方，究竟是什么会推动你试图去强烈地改变你身上的那一部分呢？我想我有一个答案，对吧？我认为这 realmente 归结于这样一个事实：人们常常觉得社会是为某种非常特定类型或特定外向程度的人而建造的，而不是为内向的人，更绝对不是为那些过于外向的人准备的。其实我收到过一位听众关于这方面的留言，这真的启发我做了这个话题。她谈到，在一个对我们的所有描绘都是
CEOs are quite brash, bold, loud leaders with big personalities or, you know, every job in the spotlight seems to involve a great level of socializing. You know, that doesn't look appealing if you are an introvert. I will say, introverts aren't often in the spotlight because, you know, typically they're going to keep away from it because it's very exhausting. That doesn't mean that they don't exist and that there isn't representation, recognition, great appreciation for the introverts in our society, even if they're not the front runners, even if they're not the people that are put on the main stage, they are still, there
首席执行官（CEO）都是些性格张扬、大胆、声音洪亮且极具个性的领导者的世界里，当你天生比较安静、天生不那么自信、或者天生对建立人脉不太感兴趣时，要觉得能够获得成功是多么困难；或者你知道的，每一个聚光灯下的工作似乎都需要极高的社交水平。你知道的，如果你是一个内向的人，这看起来并没有什么吸引力。我要说的是，内向的人并不常处于聚光灯下，因为你知道的，通常他们会刻意避开，因为这非常耗费精力。但这并不意味着他们不存在，并不意味着在我们的社会中没有对内向者的代表、认可和高度赞赏，即使他们不是领跑者，即使他们不是被推上主舞台的人，他们依然在，
are still sorry, so many examples of people who are incredibly successful. Barack Obama famously has talked about how he is an introvert. Albert Einstein was an introvert. Bill Gates introvert. Steven Spielberg, also an introvert. Eleanor Roosevelt was apparently quite introverted as well. Warren Buffett. Marissa Maya. She was the founder of Yahoo. Like there are so many examples. Don't let, you know, modern media and our very individualistic depictions of success make it seem like you are either too quiet or too too loud to find what you really want. I want to talk about how we can actually manage our natural state or our natural level of energy and desire for socialization in a world that really favors extroversion. And even better, how to balance friendship. and relationships when personalities differ,
抱歉，依然有无数成功人士的典例。奥巴马就曾以其内向性格而闻名。阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦是一个内向的人。比尔·盖茨是内向的。史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格也是内向的。埃莉诺·罗斯福显然也非常内向。沃伦·巴菲特。玛丽莎·梅耶尔，她是雅虎的创始人。这样的例子实在太多了。不要让现代媒体和我们那种极其个人主义的成功画像，让你觉得自己的性格要么太安静要么太吵闹，以至于无法找到你真正想要的东西。我想谈谈我们如何在极其偏爱外向性格的世界里，去管理我们自然的心理状态或自然的能量水平以及社交渴望。更好的是，当个性不同时，如何平衡友谊
how to network, how to be socially active, and do what's socially necessary without being, you know, drowned out by that constant, like, noise in your brain and that constant, like, perhaps tiredness. I think if you're an introvert and you're struggling with this, the first thing I want you to do is really devote your energy to those and what matters most.
和人际关系，如何建立人脉，如何保持社交活跃，以及如何完成社交上的必要事情，同时又不被大脑中那种持续的噪音和可能持续的疲惫感所淹没。我想如果你是一个内向的人并且正在为此苦恼，我希望你做的第一件事，就是将你的精力真正投入到那些最重要的人和事上。
Try and figure out how many hours is your maximum amount, for socializing before you become perhaps, you know, not someone who's that fun to be around, you know, someone who you don't really like. When you start to hit a wall, take notice. How many hours have you been in this situation? How many days in a row have you felt like you've needed to do things? Really trust your intuition and trust your body when it is asking for refueling time and almost figure out, okay, is it fire? hours a day that I can socialize is it too I'm going to use those hours as best as possible and not try and go over them I think this obviously takes some trial and error but I've had people
试着弄清楚，在你开始变得不那么好相处、甚至开始讨人嫌之前，你每天社交的极限时间是多少小时？当你开始撞墙（感到精疲力竭）时，请注意这一点。你在这种环境中待了多少个小时？连续几天你都觉得不得不做这些事？当你的身体要求补充能量时，请真正信任你的直觉和身体，并几乎去弄清楚：好吧，我每天可以社交五个小时吗？还是两个小时？我要把这些时间尽可能最好地利用起来，而不要试着超出它们。我想这显然需要一些反复试验，但我曾听人
tell me how keeping a journal for three weeks where they track hours around others I was socializing versus their mood was very very helpful for them to identify their specific cutoff basically you want to follow the very simple principle of make time for what matters and don't feel like you're selfish, don't feel guilty for saying, you know, I don't have space for this on my plate right now, especially when it's things that, you know, perhaps are a little bit unnecessary or perhaps is leaning more into a people-pleasing territory where you're only doing it to make somebody else happy. If you're only at the social event, if you're only in the meeting that was voluntary because you think it's going to make someone else happy. Making yourself miserable is not
告诉我，写三周的日记来追踪他们与他人相处的时间、社交情况与情绪的关系，这对于他们找出自己特定的能量红线非常有帮助。基本上，你想遵循一个非常简单的原则：为重要的事情腾出时间，不要觉得自己很自私，当你说“我目前实在腾不出空来处理这个”时不要感到内疚，特别是当这些事情其实有点没必要，或者更倾向于讨好他人、仅仅为了让别人高兴才去做的时候。如果你参加社交活动，或者仅仅因为你觉得能让别人高兴而参加那些自愿参加的会议。让自己痛苦并
going to make that person happy. Like making yourself miserable as well is going to bite you in the tush. So have strong boundaries around that. Know your limits. I also think in terms of keeping up conversations or giving the appearance of meeting energy levels, especially when you know you pit your wall, but like there's no way out. Here are some tips I use as like a primarily, an extrovert that I think you're a small lift in those situations so that you can still be present. You don't feel like you're being rude, but also maintain some sense of peace, like when you don't want to be in that situation or when you do, but you are like getting quite tired. Firstly, I would say ask people about themselves.
不会让那个人高兴。而且让自己痛苦最终也会反噬你自己。所以在这方面设立坚定的边界。了解你的极限。我也认为，在维持对话或展现出迎合能量水平的外表方面，特别是当你明知自己已经精疲力竭却无路可逃时，这里有一些我作为一个主要是外向者所使用的小贴士，我认为在那种情况下你可以稍作调整，这样你依然可以保持在场，不会觉得自己很不礼貌，但同时也能保持某种内心的平静，比如当你不想处于那种境地，或者当你其实想参与但却变得相当疲惫的时候。首先，我会说，多向别人询问他们自己的事。
People love that. A recent study I was reading said that most people spend the majority of their days thinking about themselves. So if they can bring that to a conversation and talk about themselves, even better. Like literally my secret is just to be like, why to everything they say, but with a few more words. Like if you ask someone what their job is at a party and they say, oh, I'm an accountant. Sometimes that can really stump people because you're like, you know, what do I talk about with that? But you can ask the why question.
人们都很喜欢这样。我最近读的一项研究表明，大多数人把一天中的大部分时间都用来思考自己。所以如果他们能把这一点带入对话并谈论他们自己，那就再好不过了。字面意义上，我的秘诀就是对他们所说的一切都问“为什么”，只不过多用几个词。比如你在派对上问别人的工作是什么，他们说，哦，我是一名会计。有时这真的会把人问住，因为你会想：关于这个我能聊些什么呢？但你可以问“为什么”这个问题。
Okay, why are they an accountant? And then be like, oh, what made you want to do that? And then say they say what it is and, you know, it's because my parents did that and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Oh, and why did your parents inspire you so much? Why did maths seem like so much fun? Literally embody a four-year-old who just has endless curiosity and ask why, but just with a few more words. And ask open questions. Smile, nod, make eye contact.
好吧，他们为什么会成为一名会计？然后接着说：哦，是什么让你想做这个？然后假设他们说出了原因，你知道的，因为我父母就是做这个的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。哦，为什么你的父母对你启发这么大？为什么数学看起来这么有意思？简直就像化身一个有着无尽好奇心、不断追问“为什么”的四岁小孩，只不过多用了几个词。多问开放式问题。微笑，点头，有眼神交流。
You don't have to do even half of the talking if you engage in active listening. So it might save you a lot of energy resources. And I promise you, like, someone will leave that interaction with you and be like, wow, they were so interesting because they just found themselves interesting. Like, that's the whole secret. I will also say kind of on a different note, but quality over quantity is something that I think we extroverts could learn to do better when it comes to saying yes, yes to friendships, to plans and whatever it is.
如果你积极倾听，你甚至不需要说出一半的话。这可能会为你节省大量的精力。我向别人保证，有人结束了与你的互动后会说：哇，他们太有趣了，因为他们让他们自己觉得很有趣。看，这就是全部的秘密。我还想说，换个角度来看，质量优于数量是我们这些外向者在对友谊、对计划以及其他任何事情说“好、好”时可以学着做得更好的地方。
And my introverted friends are definitely experts at this. So if you've found your balance, keep doing it. Don't think that just because someone else's life looks different to yours, that it's any better than yours. That is a fallacy that we very much love to lean into as humans. We think everyone is happier than us just because they do it differently or just because they present as being happier, not realizing that I think happiness is deeply individualistic and personal.
而我那些内向的朋友在这方面绝对是专家。所以如果你已经找到了你的平衡点，那就坚持下去。不要以为别人的生活看起来跟你的不同，就觉得它比你的好。作为人类，我们非常喜欢陷入这种谬误。我们以为每个人都比我们更快乐，仅仅因为他们的方式不同，或者仅仅因为他们表现得更快乐，却没有意识到我认为快乐是深深地个人化和个体化的。
If you know that you're an introvert, don't try and fit into an extrovert skin. If you know you're an extrovert, don't try and shut yourself down to be more like an introvert because you think it's going to be more appealing to people. Both individuals are going to end up unhappy. The thing is, when we talk about extroverts and introverts, at whatever point on the spectrum you sit in the moment or across your life, each of us contributes a perfect amount to humanity. And each of us, in whatever form we come, I think is balanced by someone else. else out there who was hopefully being their most authentic self and who is you don't filling the bit
如果你知道自己是个内向的人，就不要试图去套上外向者的皮囊。如果你知道自己是个外向的人，就不要试图压抑自己去假装内向，只因为你觉得这样会更讨人喜欢。这两种人最终都会过得不快乐。关键是，当我们谈论外向者和内向者时，无论你此刻或一生中处于光谱的哪一个点上，我们每个人都对人类做出了完美的贡献。而且我们每个人，无论以何种形式出现，我认为都被这个世界上的另一个人所平衡着，
that we don't feel so if you're an extrovert you have your introverted um balancing act like there's someone else in the world who provides what the world needs in an opposition to you basically like we need everyone you play a role even if you think that you're too much or you're too little i truly believe in like the harmony and the balance of this world and maybe even the universe at large. And this is one aspect of it, a tiny, tiny micro aspect of it, but it's an important one. You know, I hate ending on something as cliche as like, be yourself. But this is so, so true. Like, I hope you take away from this episode, how much value we each bring, how we need
那个希望正在做最真实的自己、并且正在填补我们所空缺的那一部分人。所以如果你是一个外向者，你有你的内向平衡机制——世界上有另一个人在提供世界所需要的东西，与你形成互补。基本上，我们需要每一个人。你扮演着一个角色，即使你认为自己付出得太多或太少。我真的坚信这个世界乃至整个宇宙的和谐与平衡。这是其中的一个方面，一个极其微小的方面，但却是一个重要的方面。你知道的，我很讨厌以像“做你自己”这样陈词滥调的话来收尾。但事实确实如此。我希望你从这期节目中汲取到：我们每个人带来了多少价值，我们需要
extroverts, we need introverts, whatever you are. We need everyone to make the world go around. So if you are questioning, can I change myself? Can I be happier? Can I be more like that person? Please really contemplate whether being more like that person, a person who you were not born to be, is going to make you any happier, or whether really leaning in to the strengths of your introversion, or the strengths of your extroversion, what it makes you amazing at, what it makes you so talented at, what it brings to society, that that is actually going to make you happy. Like a real sense of a stubbornness to yourself, a sense of surrender, a sense of complete acceptance. I think that's all we have for this episode. Thank you so much for bearing with my sick, gross voice for this many minutes.
外向者，我们也需要内向者，无论你是什么样的人。我们需要所有人才能让世界运转。所以如果你在质疑：我能改变自己吗？我能更快乐吗？我能更像那个人吗？请认真思考一下，变得更像那个人——一个并非天生注定要成为的人——真的会让你更快乐吗？还是说，真正去倾注于你内向性格的优势，或是你外向性格的优势，去发挥你擅长什么、你有什么天赋、你为社会带来了什么，这才是真正能让你快乐的东西。那种对自我的顽强坚守、那种臣服、那种完全的接纳。我想这就是本期节目的全部内容了。非常感谢大家忍受我这把生病、沙哑的破嗓子坚持了这么久。
I appreciate it if you've made it this far. In the comments below, I want you to leave your Myers-Briggs or your Big Five personality kind of traits, whether you are an extrovert or an introvert. I really want to hear whether people in my audience lean more one towards the other. Maybe I'll even pop a poll down there because I would be very, very fascinated by that information. I hope you learned more about yourself from this episode. If you feel like there's someone else in your life who could get something out of this,
如果你能听到这里，我真的非常感激。在下方的评论区，我希望大家留下你们的迈尔斯-布里格斯类型（MBTI）或者大五人格的特质，以及你们是外向还是内向。我真的很想听听我的听众里到底是偏向哪一种的人更多。也许我甚至会在下面发一个投票，因为我对这些信息会非常非常感兴趣。希望你通过这期节目对自我有了更多的了解。如果你觉得你生活中的其他人也能从中获益，
feel free to share it with them, start a conversation, share it to your Instagram story and see what people think. It's also really a great way for me to reach new people and to hopefully build this community, which we always love. Make sure that you are following along. You leave a five-star review, only if you feel called to do so. And you can also follow me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you have questions, queries, qualms, conundrums, further comments or even episode suggestions, my DMs are always open and as always, until next time, stay safe, be kind, be done. gentle to yourself and we will talk very, very soon.
请随时分享给他们，开启一场对话，把它分享到你的Instagram快拍上，看看大家是怎么想的。这也是我触达新听众、建立我们一直热爱的这个社群的绝佳方式。请确保关注本节目。留下五星好评，前提是你觉得有此意愿。你也可以在Instagram上关注我，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。如果你有任何问题、疑问、困惑、难题、进一步的评论甚至是节目建议，我的私信永远向你敞开。一如既往，直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己
On the Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。在 Look Back at it 播客节目中。1979年，对我来说是个大日子。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何撑过那段日子的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家们一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的 Learn the Hard Way。这个栏目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人披着铠甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023年，美国广播公司（ABC）《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
你两次伪造了这个特定的测试，程度很深。我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《被困之爱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and build.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客 2% 中，我将剖析心理韧性、体能的科学，并在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中构建
and resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
坚韧的品质。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 2%。节目名称是数字 2 加百分号。当一群女性发现
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
她们都曾和同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。收听《好姐妹，相信我，宝贝》。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。人类出品，品质保证。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。